- It is so nice to meet you.
- It's great to meet you too.
I'm such a huge fan.
- I am as well.
I'm so excited for you
congrats on "In The Heights".
- Thank you, thank you.
- I heard that Lin actually
called you personally.
- Yes.
- Yeah, how was that like?
- That was incredible.
It was a shock
because I got the call from
a random, like 917 number,
and it was actually
the day of my birthday.
So I was, you know, on your birthday
you get calls maybe from
people (indistinct) your phone.
My mom was doing my hair.
And I was like I'll get back to this.
It was a FaceTime.
And then the same number
texts me and was like,
"Hey, it's Lin, can you
pick up real quick?"
And I was like, "Mom,
what I'm gonna tell him?
Wait for 10 minutes?
Like, he's gonna have
to see me like this."
So I picked up.
He had no idea it was my birthday.
And he was calling me to let me know
that I got the role for
Nina "In The Heights".
- What an amazing thing on your birthday?
- Yeah, it was like the best birthday gift
I've ever received,
I think probably will receive.
- Well you sent us a video of
that call, so let's see it.
- Yeah.
- [Lin] Celebrate tonight
(speaks in foreign language).
- Yes.
(laughing)
Thank you for telling mum
to put the iron towel.
She definitely would have
turned the hell out of my head.
(speaks in foreign language)
Thank you so much.
(mumbling)
I'll see you in Washington
in "In The Heights".
Bye my love, enjoy.
(audience clapping)
- Oh my God, it's so crazy.
What a cool thing to have?
- It was like one of the best moments.
Also it was really full circle
just to have my mum there.
She was doing my hair
and one of my best friends was there.
My cousin who did my first ever read
before I was any good at acting with
he was there and we were just balling.
- Oh, see, I don't believe in coincidence.
I think it was supposed to happen
like everything that was for you.
- Definitely.
- That's so cool.
What a cool memory to keep
with you forever, God.
- That's beautiful.
- Well the movie is about
embracing your differences.
So how do you relate to that?
- Oh man, I definitely
grew up in a household
that embraced all of our differences.
My parents are both Dominican.
I'm the youngest of seven
where like a Brady bunch fam.
Yeah, we're a big family.
So I got siblings from both sides.
And then the youngest two including myself
are from both my parents.
But it was a little bit different
when we moved to Florida.
I was raised in New York till I was 10
then we moved to Florida
and my big curly hair
and being Afro-Latino was kind of a shock
that I didn't realize
would be for some people
once I moved to a place where
there weren't a lot of people
that look like me.
And so being able to
even just do a project
like "In The Heights"
and feel fully accepted
and even learn how to
celebrate where I'm from
more through the plot of our movie
was such a beautiful thing
and it's something that
we don't always get to see
in Hollywood.
And it's something that we
don't always get to experience
in playing a role in a film or in a show.
So it was beautiful on my
first experience as an actress
to experience that.
- Yeah, I can't even imagine
just as an artist in general
to get to do something
that also has a message
that means so much to you
that you can relate to.
That's the coolest thing,
you're getting to do something
you love and your passion,
but also it's like leaving behind
really positive footprints.
- Yeah.
- I love that.